okay let's move the 2222 a these were
two free marks identified three
different multimedia elements on this
page okay now by the way even though
it's why why mr. Woodroof why did you
put such an easy question in such a
ridiculously hard exam okay because if
you look up the border studies and if
you haven't already we're going to over
the next few weeks if you've looked up
the border studies you'll see they
always have a question like this in the
multimedia section they give you a
website or some kind of piece of
software right and they say hey there's
some multimedia elements here can you
tell me what they are right free Mars
okay the key was that you had to wrote
identify specific elements so you guys
got lucky that it said like things like
video and images down the bottom but if
you just said audio you said audio for
star so well which element are you
talking about maybe you met music right
for audio is a data type that's not
actually specifically mentioned there so
if you accidentally did that them oops
but those are otherwise it's very easy
months now the real kicker was in
question B right so it was kind of a
sneaky part a because you need to know
what you did for Part A - here's a puppy
ah okay
outline appropriate organizing methods
what's organizing me organizing in this
course what does organizing mean yes
that's right you're gonna do something
to these files so that you knew
something else right in the case of a
website you're mainly preparing them for
transmitting and receiving okay so
therefore you organize them you format
the files in such a way that they're
good for transmitting or receiving now
most of you swore to God that the idea
was data compression right but you need
to say
yeah the images well would put them in
JPEG that's the way you organize them
organizing is not um they were laid out
in a nice orderly line at the bottom of
the page in a very organized fashion
rather than put in a random file that's
not organizing okay that's organizing in
a general sense but you guys have been
doing this for months
you know organizing means
boss right again three easy rise
pottsy okay let's see here let's scroll
down yeah yeah I'll list out a whole
bunch here for you now the point of me
listing these hour is so that some of
you I think felt like men
two kinds of I can't think of two kinds
of jobs that's so hot I could feel as I
read your answers that you are really
stretching your like I don't know they
people people hold the mic I guess you
know that's it's okay I think I paid
that because I felt somewhat bad for you
right but these are really what we told
you that right animated 3d modelers
effect pyrotechnics
sound effects Foley a lot of people said
Foley because we spend like half a
lesson on it so if you are looking for -
there's tons ok this is plenty here now
you had to talk about because the
question says describe right describe
the jobs don't just tell me okay
there was a job animator full stop okay
you need to describe the nature and
function of those jobs particularly in
relation to the data they produced
because it says specifically related to
the production of multimedia components
okay so that's what I was looking for to
get there for max - for each different
role any questions on that right so the
top of this and this is Part D this is
getting via the file size and it says in
brackets do not evaluate the file size
but some of you like yeah Oh Jade your
student I mean today I'm gonna evaluate
it anyway if you did that into dark
marks but anyway okay so when the
numbers come from um you tell me 130
what's that minutes okay so this wool
160 1666
okay the 60s to get it in two seconds
because all of the ways that you're
going to work out all these other
numbers they have to do with frames per
second or you know a bit rate that kind
of thing they're all measured in per
second nine per minute okay now what's
this what's this business here the aten
the 1024 what's the 8 bits in two bytes
right cuz you're gonna get this invites
it is calculated in gigabytes and in
this 10,000 sorry 1024 right I've got a
cubit because I've gone for a but two
kilobytes to megabytes to gigabytes
right so I've gone to three times this
year that's for free that was the
resolution everyone got that 24 is the
bit-depth having colors right once is 30
some people miss that and why is it
connected to here here's the here's how
many pixels here's how many each pixel
takes and this is how many frames per
second right because it says at 30
frames per second in the first sentence
yeah now over here 44100 that's going to
be your audio bitrate so 44 point 1
kilohertz you had to get that a 32 32
bit depth that's easy
now some people have said either 5 or
5.1 anyone supplied by 5.1 no 5.1 Dolby
surround sound what are what are the
five and the one by the way though
they're the different channels yeah so
the five refer to you've got one main
speaker then you've got four corners so
that gives you five okay and then you've
got one verse you've got the subwoofer
okay don't ask me why it's not just
called six surround sound I don't know
like 5.1 because the numbers later it's
2d part I didn't get that but it's six
okay so you need to get that there were
six channels otherwise you probably just
mister miss the little item okay